frente a nosotros tenemos otra captura
de pantalla de canacar de mí y le he
modificado un poco para que tengamos
espacio extra y dice divide los
polinomios la forma de tu respuesta debe
ser un polinomio o un polinomio más el
residuo sobre x 5 que tenemos aquí en el
denominador donde p de x es un polinomio
y acá es un número entero hemos hecho
cosas como esta pero como siempre te
invito a que pases el vídeo y trabajes
esto por tu cuenta y si estuvieras
haciendo esto en cana academy aquí
habría un pequeño cuadro donde tendrías
que escribir la respuesta pero hagámoslo
en papel muy bien estamos tratando de
calcular cuánto es x menos 5 que divide
a 12 x a la tercera potencia en realidad
quiero tener cuidado aquí porque quiero
tener muy organizadas las columnas por
grados entonces esta es mi columna de
tercer grado y luego quiero mi columna
de segundo grado pero no hay un término
de segundo grado aquí hay un término de
primer grado así que le escribiré aquí
unos 47 x observa que para ser aún más
cuidadosa escribiré más 0 x al cuadrado
y luego tengo menos 15 al poner más 0 x
al cuadrado me aseguro de hacerlo bien
supongo que esto me ayudará muy bien
ahora podemos trabajar en esto y primero
podríamos decir cuántas veces cabe x en
el término de mayor grado aquí bueno x
cabe en 12 x a la tercera potencia 2 x x
al cuadrado veces quiero poner esto en
la columna de segundo grado 2 x al
cuadrado
puedes ver cómo se habría desordenado si
hubiera puesto menos 47 x aquí diría
donde pongo 2 x al cuadrado y podrías
confundirte y no queremos que eso suceda
de acuerdo 2 x al cuadrado x menos 5 es
igual a menos 10 x al cuadrado 2 x al
cuadrado por x es 2 x a la tercera
potencia ahora queremos restar lo que
tenemos en rojo de lo que tenemos en
azul
entonces los multiplicar por menos 1
esto se convierte en negativo y luego
este se convierte en positivo y en
realidad aquí es donde suceden los más
grandes errores por descuido si tienes
un signo negativo aquí y quieres
restarlo porque sabes que tienes que
restar lo piensas estoy restando un
negativo y tiene que ser positivo muy
bien entonces 0 x al cuadrado más 10 x
al cuadrado es 10 x al cuadrado y luego
2x en la tercera potencia menos 2x en la
tercera potencia es igual a 0 y luego
podemos bajar menos 47 x y una vez más
nos fijamos en los términos de mayor
grado x cabe en 10 x al cuadrado 10 x
veces así que escribimos más 10 x 10 x x
menos 5 es igual a menos 50 x 10 x x x
es 10 x al cuadrado y una vez más
queremos restar lo que tenemos en azul
verdoso de lo que tenemos en rojo así
que podemos multiplicar estos dos x
menos 1 esto se convierte en negativo
este se convierte en positivo
ahora menos 47 x 50 x es igual a 13 x
positivo y luego 10 x al cuadrado menos
10 x al cuadrado se cancelan bajamos
este 15
cuántas veces cabe x en 13 x cabe 3
veces 3 x menos 5 es igual a menos 15 3
por x es 3x queremos restarlo naranja de
lo azul verdoso de modo que esto se
convierte en negativo esto se convierte
en positivo menos 15 15 es 0 y 3 x 3 x
es igual a cero te quedas con 0 por lo
tanto no hay residuo así que podemos
expresar o simplificar esto como 2 x al
cuadrado más 10 x + 3 y una vez más si
esto estuviera en khan academy habría un
cuadro de entrada que se parece a esto y
tendrías que escribirlo ahora si
quisieras que ésta fuera exactamente la
misma expresión tendrías que restringir
el dominio sería para x diferente de 5 y
la razón por la que tenemos que
restringir esto es porque podemos
dividir entre x
estamos suponiendo que x 5 no es igual a
0 y generalmente no será igual a 0
siempre y cuando x no sea igual a 5
positivo pero por el bien de este
ejercicio no es necesario restringir el
dominio de esta manera